tricératops
sense qu'est-ce tu fais je faisais le
bilan de 2014 ah ça a été une grosse
année quand même regarde ça on a hébergé
le Captain iglou et le Père Noël pendant
15 jours on a formé une communauté pour
retrouver des cristaux magiques j'ai
découvert que mon grand-père était un
extraterrestre tu as eu le prix campag
2014 au Japon pour le meilleur karaokeé
bravo encore d'ailleurs on a foutu le
feu Unx qui est plutôt étrange quand j'y
repense 48 kebab ont ouvert grâce à nous
j'ai fait une om dooc deux fois et pour
Noël j'ai été possédé par le diable et
j'ai essayé de te tuer
ouais c'est vrai alors nouvelle
résolution pour
2015 je sais pas un nouveau générique
[Rires]
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
salut tout le monde et bonne année 2015
et pour commencer on va parler de cool
World sur supernesses mais tout d'abord
on va parler du film parce que même si
vous êtes certainement nombreux à
connaître Roger habit ou Marie Popin
dans le même genre vous êtes sûrement
pas très nombreux à connaître cool World
essentiellement parce que c'est un film
de merde torché avec le cul cool World
film sorti en 92 réalisé par Ralph
Bakshi notamment connu pour avoir
réalisé le Seigneur des Anneaux non non
non non non non celui-là
voilà bref un grand moment de cinéma
pour ce film le scénario est nul à chier
les acteurs sont complètement en rou
libre avec un bras de Pit qui est en
mode j'en ai strictement rien à branler
les personnages et l'histoire sont
absolument pas introduits genen
regardais cette scène c'est la première
scène du film où on voit le héros oui je
sais tu n'es qu'un dessin mais sans toi
je n'aurais jamais tenu le coup alors il
faut que tu m'embrasses
[Musique]
j'adore ton cul je suis dans un anim et
surtout c'est un repompage absolument
violent de Roger habbit film noir pinup
mélange dessin animé réalité et cool
World c'est film noir pinup mélange des
animé réalité mais en moins bien et en
plus vulgaire tenz à la place d'une
Jessica Rabit sexy et volcanique ici on
a une blonde qui est
c'est quoi le mot
c'est
chaude tout le film tourne autour de la
frustration sexuelle les nanas dessin
animés veulent baiser les mecs les mecs
veulent baiser les nanas dessin animés
mais il existe une loi qui interdit aux
T et aux humains de se mélanger quand
finalement olit décide de sauter le pas
ce qui crée une espèce de de de
singularité vaginale qui la transforme
en
[Musique]
humaine et pour le reste du film
j'ai pas compris non c'est non j'ai pas
compris ça n'a aucun sens tu tu
comprends pas vraiment où le film veut
t'emmener il y a aucune règle cohérente
le climax à la fin du film tu en as rien
à [ __ ] je elle veut planter une espèce
de flèche blanche sur le toit d'un
immeuble là aucune idée de pourquoi
j'ai
RG enfin bref c'est de la merde en fait
cool World c'est un peu l'ultime mélange
entre midi les zouu et youporn de Dieu
c'est quoi ces trucs qui apparaissent de
manière totalement random dans le film
genre genre tu es au milieu d'une scène
et puis d'un coup il y a ça vas-y fais
ce que tu veux excusez-moi monsieur la
bête c'est bien par là donc pour une
raison étrange cool World a été adapté
en une chier de jeu sur Game Boy sur NES
sur Super NES sur Atari ST sur Amiga et
il va falloir qu' m'explique le
marketing là je va dire pourquoi autant
de jeux qui veut les acheter pour qui on
acheté les jeux à l'époque pour les
gamins qui va aller voir ce film pas les
gamins j'espère ça serait biz
[Applaudissements]
papa elle a quoi la madame et ben écoute
là tu vois la madame comment on dit chez
nous elle a la Garon en cru et pourtant
faut croire que si t on a une version
Atar St développée par océan avec
Jean-Michel bruitage au
[Musique]
son un jeu en deux disquettes d'ailleurs
de la première des deux disquettes n'est
réservé qu'à un seul truc c
[Musique]
une disquette que tu mets 2 minutes à
l'Oder et qui ne sert à rien d'autre que
voir ça il y a pas de jeu dessus
complètement inutile
ça va pass à la
[Musique]
suite elle fait mousser la bière elle
est amaréotte
elle a la rosée qui perle mais bon on va
pas spécialement en parler parce que le
jeu en lui-même il est plutôt classique
c'est pas très intéressant c'est un
plateformeur très basique de même que la
version Game Boy qui est une bête
adaptation de la version Atari ST oh
[ __ ] c'est triste que la seule chose
qu'on retient ce film c'est une blonde
àle qui se trémousse c'est même pas le
personnage principal du film en plus bon
bref on va commencer par la version la
plus récente CW sur supern sortie en 92
donc le jeu alors les
contrôles oh mon dieu oh mon dieu ça pue
la merde oh non non oh non non oh mon
dieu non non ça c'est criminel ok alors
avant même de parler du jeu on va parler
des contrôles parce que ça là c'est
juste illégal pour taper en l'air c'est
X pour taper normal c'est B les deux
boutons pour taper déjà sont à l'opposé
l'un de l'autre aut mais surtout le
bouton saut est sur Y ça se fait pas ça
se fait pas c'est sale c'est sale c'est
c'est pas illégal mais c'est comme
[ __ ] sa cousine ça se fait pas je
veux dire comprenez que rien n'oblige un
développeur à mettre le bouton saut où
il veut mais sur presque tous les jeux
et toutes les consoles depuis la
SuperNes le bouton saut est toujours à
la base du pouce normalement c'est une
espèce de convention taite qui a été
plus ou moins installé par Mario alors
pourquoi pourquoi vouloir changer comme
ça les choses quand ça marche vous savez
qui d'autrre voulait changer les choses
comme ça les nazis bravo totalement
convaincu là ouais non sérieusement on
retrouve aussi ce problème sur les
ennemis dans le jeu regarde là ce mec je
peux pas lui sauter dessus lui je peux
mais ça le tue pas cet ennemi je peux le
tuer alors qu'il bouge pas elle je peux
pas mais attends là je peux alors
attends la version d'or je peux mais la
version dedans non et c'est la même
[ __ ] et ça aussi alors ça j'aime bien
alors ça ça ça fond dans la bouche les
détonateurs bleus j'en prends un je
meurs bon ben ok ben alors je les prends
plus mais bien sûr que si ma pauvre
luette seulement il des ble qui explose
et il y a des détonateurs bleus qui
explosent pas et qu'il faut absolument
ramasser pour pas être bloqué dans le
jeu voilà le foot c'est des modé ce
qu'ils aiment les enfants de 8 à 12 ans
là c'est c'est la roulette rus on le
sait tous gros doigt sérieusement les
règles changent tout le temps ce jeu il
a autant de cohérence qu' épisode de
Salut les Musclés c'est toujours pareil
[ __ ] toujours le même [ __ ] de
problème quand tu établis une règle tu
t'y tiens [ __ ] B de bal chot le jeu
vidéo c'est comme toutes les autres
activités ludiques c'est pas un monde
merveilleux où on emmerde la logique le
but est refusé parce que je suis
fou je sens que tout le jeu ça va être
ça ah là là c'est complètement décalé on
est complètement des artistes il faut
utiliser le bouquet de fleurs trouvé
dans la librairie sur le videer pour
rentrer dans la boîte de nuit c'est
complètement foufou je suis totalement
déchaîné je défait un bouton de de ma
chemise c'est la folie à son paroxisme
non [ __ ] vous êtes juste des phases de
cul quoi ça rend juste le jeu infaisable
de manière légitime du coup tu es obligé
d'avoir une soluce sinon tu t'en sors
pas et autant ok un truc un peu barré
qui t'oblige avoir une soluce dans un
point and click je veux bien de toute
façon tu es là pour l'histoire mais
[ __ ] pas dans un jeu de
plateforme bon de toute façon
franchement j'aurais eu la soluce
j'aurais pas cru ce qu'il fallait faire
dans le niveau des bonbons récupérez un
miiccheake dans la bouche du chat avec
votre [ __ ] et posez-le sur la bûche de
Noël pour attirer les vieilles
merci bref finalement le jeu est assez
petit he seulement quatre tableaux
différents et du coup tu sens qu'ils ont
tout fait pour augmenter un petit peu la
durée de vie de leur jeu et comment tu
fais pour augmenter la durée de vie de
ton jeu quand tu es un gland et ben tu
rajoutes des tableaux de merde
impossibles à passer où tu vas gaspiller
toutes tes vies bienvenue sur le niveau
Salvador Dali je vais je vais tomber je
vais tomber je vais c'était sûr c'était
sûr comment c'est possible regarde ça
les deux routes sont en face l'une de
l'autre j'atterris dessus et je tombe
bordel de merde dans ce niveau la
perspective n'a plus aucun sens et tu as
de la merde sur la route tout le long tu
peux tu peux pas faire 2 mètr sans
cogner un truc [ __ ]
[ __ ] doucement
doucement trop doucement donc voilà
c'est l'éclate c'est le fun tu es obligé
d'aller vite parce que si tu vas trop
doucement tu as pas assez d'élamp pour
sauter les trous et si tu vas trop vite
tu te bouffes toutes les merdes sur le
trajet et tu as trop d' lampes pour
passer les trous merci le plafond [ __ ]
[ __ ] je déteste ces niveaux ça sert
juste à allonger la durée de vie d'un
jeu en le rendant impossible c'est
littéralement du Viagra pour développeur
nul vas-y remets-moi l'autre jeu là
celui avec la blonde qui danse là bah
quoi tu veux pas voir la suite oui c'est
vrai ben je meurs d'envie de passer ce
niveau je veux voir la suite de ce jeu
absolument [ __ ] de merde mais c'est
pas vrai qui c'est qui a développer ce
jeu Chantal Goya non mais regardez ce
game design c'est incroyable on dirait
qu'il y a une licorne qui vient de chier
un arc-en-ciel sur écran ouais Babouche
j'arrive à entendre les couleurs et tu
sais
[Musique]
quoi j'ai oublié bon visiblement je peux
pas tuer les lapins mais s'il y a bien
un truc que Disney nous a appris c'est
que la vie des gens moches a moins de
valeur que la vie des gens beau alors
mourrez les moches et je peux pas parler
de tout mais des fois dans le jeu de
manière totalement aléatoire le jeu
t'envoie à Las Vegas pour faire le
ménage voilà c'est des fois dans le jeu
comme ça c'est un événement aléatoire on
sait pas trop comment voilà c'est
l'équivalent du jeu qui te dit va ranger
ta chambre évidemment ça prend longtemps
ramasser il faut ê P dessus voilà sinon
ça marche pas et tant que tuas pas fini
tu peux pas partir voilà c'est c'est
incroyable ce
passage viens jouer au jeux vidéo on SCL
je
vidéoun des fois ça bouge aussi oubl
parce que c'est plus rigolo he parce que
c'est rigolo ça quand même on est
d'accord là c'est marrant c'est
l'éclate c'est c'est génial là [ __ ]
mais bouge pas mais mais va te faire
[ __ ] mais non pas là mais put
[Musique]
ok stop on a déjà fait ce Gug c'est
incroyable je je sais pas ce qu'il aura
quand ils ont fait ce niveau vraiment
allez au moins celui-là il est gros
celui-là ça
[Musique]
va [ __ ] je' foutrai du les jeux
c'était mieux avant bordel c'est quoi
cette punition sérieux bonus stage à
l'envers de l'enfer là vous avez de la
chance de pas voir ça dans les jeux
récents ditesvous
[Musique]
allez je suivant cool World sur NES
alors est-ce que vous vous souvenez de
cette scène dans le film où Brad pit
arrive dans une tornade et commence à
buter des tunes dans la rue et ben si
vous vous en souvenez vous avez
probablement une tumeur au cerveau le
jeu sur NES N a absolument plus rien à
branler du film mais mais vraiment plus
rien et d'ailleurs au passage et comme
vous voyez on joue br pite on le
reconnaît bien avec son son menton
énorme là et ses cheveux noirs et nous
évoluons donc dans un monde haut en
couleur en tout cas il y en a trois déjà
il y a le violet le bleu et le vert et
nous sommes assaillis par des hamster
exhibitionnistes sur fond de musique du
Jacky Cho c'est une réaction je passe on
peut ramasser des bombes des gommes qui
servent à regagner de la vie mais l'arme
principale du jeu pour chasser les
ennemis c'est LE PEN qu'il faut vider
régulièrement je vais dire stylo à
partir de maintenant c'est là où cette
arme devient particulièrement pourri
c'est que plus tu tues des ennemis plus
l'arme se remplit et quand elle est
pleine et ben elle marche plus génial et
du coup ben il faut utiliser les rares
récipients pour se vider le stylo
non c'est toujours aussi dégueulasse je
passe sur le niveau 1 qui un peu bâtard
au passage puisque la fin du niveau est
genre au milieu du niveau c'està-dire
que les mecs on ont fait
tout ça là là tout le reste pour rien
juste pour te faire croire qu'il faut
continuer à avancer alors qu'en fait non
et donc après cette porte on entre dans
une salle alors il faut complètement
ignorer C ennemis de sauter sur le carré
rouge qui clignote là qui n'est pas un
item mais qui est en fait une plateforme
qui clignote 3 prendre la fenêtre Cobra
qui est en réalité une porte vers une
échelle vers un égout fuck la
cohérence et 4 tout ça en évitant la
tapisserie électrifiée qui continue à
fonctionner même quand on appuie sur le
bouton
Pause ok alors on va faire un cours de
game design pour les abrutis tu vois ça
là tu te dit quoi hein tu rentres dans
une salle la musique change il y a qu'un
seul ennemi il a pas le même skin que
les ennemis que tu as déjà vu il fait
des attaques que tu as jamais vu il a un
pattern c'est un
B et un boss tu le vois tu le tues tu
lui passes pas devant ça veut rien dire
non mais merde quoi ramène ça à
n'importe quelle autre
situation te voilà
enfinwan le cercle avant accompli
tu vas où là pas par là parce que là
c'est bref et ensuite ah oui oui le
niveau dans les égoutûs évidemment c'est
super original hein personne n'a
sûrement pensé à en faire un dans un jeu
vidéo d'ailleurs c'est tellement
original que même le film y a pas pensé
autant dans dans certains jeux il te
tirent un niveau d'une microcène genre
comme le niveau de la lune d'un Dragon
Ball qui est tiré de deux pauvres
vignettes autant là à aucun moment du
film il ne va dans les égouts à aucun
moment du film il ne pense à aller dans
les égouts à aucun moment du film le mot
égû n'est prononcé et même si je voulais
rentrer dans les égouts pourquoi est-ce
que j'y rentre pas je sais pas en
passant par les égoutts bref on s'éclate
je peux pas tuer les ennemis ils
reviennent en boucle il y a des
plateformes qui bougent joie bonheur
poir à laavement et non de Dieu quand
vous faisiez ce jeu vous aviez la touche
bloquée sur couleur violette c'est pas
humain de faire un truc aussi lé [ __ ]
regardez celui-là l'école maternelle
Frédéric Méran est F de vous présenter
la presque mirale la class de Madame
Roger ah ben voilà le boss [ __ ] voilà
j'ai deviné là que c'était le boss parce
que la musique a subitement
changé ah bande de cyber clochard
sérieux faites un effort quoi ce boss on
dirait casse bonbons des ras Moquet qui
aurait
moisi ça oh [ __ ] et
l'animation regardez je suis programmeur
de jeux vidéo oh vous avez vu comme
j'anime bien les ennemis et attends j'ai
pas assez de bombe
je peux je peux pas le battre [ __ ]
parce que c'est maintenant que ça sert
les bombes ils auraient pas pu me le
dire avant cette bande de trou de balle
[ __ ] benfoiré là j'ai plus de bombe
j'ai tout pifé sur le niveau E et sur le
faux boss de mes couilles et maintenant
j'ai plus rien ce jeu il a pas de pitié
si tu as gâché ne seraitce qu'une seule
bombe sur le trajet du boss c'est mort
dégage c'est le reset parce que en plus
tu peux pas sortir de la salle du boss
évidemment et si tu meurs sur le boss tu
repopes dans la salle du boss avec juste
juste une seule bombe en plus mais il en
faut 10 pour le tuer allez suicide Game
Over merci au
revoir c'est marrant je meurs d'envie de
craquer Photoshop là tout de suite je
sais pas pourquoi et vous m'excuserez je
vous aime bien vraiment mais je vais pas
me taper tous les niveaux même s'ils
sont passionnants hein ah [ __ ] c'est
comment tu veux que je ramasse ce truc
là sérieux c'est pas possible [ __ ]
c'est quoi ce truc rester en vie est une
souffrance ah oui ce niveau est sympa
hein quand tu arrives à la fin tu dois
choisir un des trous au hasard pour
arriver à la suite du niveau perdu
lol [ __ ] c'est vraiment du caca de
première classe les plateformes piégées
qui tombent il manquait plus que ça les
portes piégées aussi ben oui vas-y bah
moi avec une fourche arrache-moi les
ongles c'est du jeu vidéo je suis là
pour bouffer ma race après tout je je
fait quoi là il y a il y a pas
de oh pu merde je suis pas obligé de
jouer à ça après tout c'est
fais B
des y vaau spa dans le
ci tu va me le payer
[Musique]
conard je suis ton futur
encore je suis toi du Pass pasier je
suis
[Musique]
jeis doit déterminer qui est l'élu allez
c'est reparti pour une nouvelle année
[Musique]